jeanine driver je comprends vous aimiez
à bernard mai mais je suis là aussi mais
là vous êtes là pour nous expliquer
votre quotidien qui était déjà pas
flamboyant mais l'année avec l'inflation
vous le ressentez de plein fouet les
conséquences ont été immédiates pauvres
ah oui c'est énorme les légumes ont peu
plus en parler on peut plus en acheter
parce que quand vous voyez un kilo
tomates 5 euros 45 vous regardez et vous
êtes effrayer donc fait marche arrière
que ce soit pour ça que ce soit pour les
fruits
hier ma fille m'a téléphoné et m'a dit
maman j'ai acheté de nectarines 2
022 euros
donc là je pense que
c'est grave on est plus que au fond on
descend vraiment très bas et on arrive à
un stade où on ne peut plus s'en sortir
du terrain alors on va détailler en fait
oui revenus vous avez 1300 euros de
retraite 350 euros vous travaillez
encore pour essayer de nom on m'a viré
on vous a viré à voilà ce que j'ai
demandé des frais kilométriques on m'a
donné 40 euros 1 centimes du kilo cox
est donc vous avez un loyer à 4 c à 620
euros vous avez l'assurance 25 euros
téléphonent 35 euros mutuelle 50 euros
carburant 519 euros dont vous parliez à
l'instant 8 sur les sacs ça vous coûte
plus cher d'aller travailler que ce que
ça vous rapporte en gros c'est pas
possible crédit voiture 250 euros et
après déduction de toutes ces charges
ivresse 150 euros par mois j'ai même pas
quoi je veux même pas décompté
l'assurance mois de juin surgelé mis
dedans ah bon donc ça veut dire que
c'est 5 euros par jour pour se nourrir
donc c'est à dire que vous ne mangez pas
3 n'ont pas d'argent non j'ai été malade
d'ailleurs il ya trois semaines je serai
pas je n'aurais pas pu être là parce que
j'étais en manque de vitamine b12
métabolisme parce que je me nourrissais
pas justement suffisamment comme je suis
aussi diabétiques voilà le problème ilic
qu'on doit avoir une alimentation
saine et oui quand on paye des pubs
manger cinq fruits et légumes par jour
c'est énorme sinon et moi je trouve que
toujours entendre dire que les retraités
la moyenne est de 2000 euros par mois
c'est faux c'est totalement 1300 s'est
de nouveau ces nouveaux smic va le
suivre et à 1300 est je crois donc celle
du smic quoi oui mais on vous prend la
csg de la dette de l'état donc il vous
reste rien quoi comment comment est-ce
qu'au quotidien on s'organise je pense
que c'est des choix permanence et on
sait de l'arbitrage quoi c'est un jour
si vous aimez pas ça sert aux
permanences hier soir j'ai mangé une
soupe aux vermicelles ce midi j'ai pas
encore mangé j'ai déjeuné de petits
gâteau ce matin voyez c'est comme ça
montre un mon train-train quotidien j'ai
acheté une tomates coeur de boeuf qui
m'a coûté 2 euros je vais manger au
moins trois quatre jours dessus parce
que j'ai pas le choix parce que c'est
énorme moi j'en suis malade d'aller dans
l'humain cattin vidal et dans les
supermarchés
pour dire ben je vais y aller pour
acheter quoi faire quoi est-ce que vous
êtes tourné je sais pas vers des
organismes parce que les restos du coeur
non non non désolé je ne fais pas partie
j'ai pas le droit à l'apl armée c'est
pour cette raison je pose la question
parce que c'est qu'ils sont à vous
plaisir et être des bouts vient de se
faire laver nous voulons c'est que vous
n'avez pas droit à l'aide
parce que ben vous dépassez place mais
on est au dessus de 50 euros soit sa rue
vous n'avez droit à rien j'aurais même
pas le chèque alimentaire que monsieur
mâcon propose et l on n'en fait pas
partie donc vous pensez que vous avez
été oubliée par le gouvernement bat vous
étrangler les oubliez moi j'ai travaillé
toute ma vie avec six enfants j'ai fait
tout ce que j'ai pu et aujourd'hui j'ai
pas j'ai rien je j'ai honte de le dire
j'ai honte d'être là parce que je trouve
que je devrais pas voir où je devrais
être avec mes enfants pouvoir les aider
et aujourd'hui j'ai honte parce que j'ai
travaillé des 72 heures par semaine et
aujourd'hui le résultat c'est que l'état
ne me donnes ne me ne leur donne pas
parce que l'état ne vous reconnaît même
pas dans le si les endurances ans et ça
vous donner ces tentes et que vous soyez
dans les bonnes cases mais vous ne
l'aimez pas non nous on est droit de
dettes dans les shales vous n'avez pas
avoir honte et celui ci j'ai honte parce
que si on apprend aussi quand j'ai
travaillé depuis l'âge de 16 ans
justement j'ai travaillé jusqu'à des 72
heures par semaine pour dire d'avoir une
retraite la carsat a osé me dire
pourquoi vous avez travaillé madame
parce que vous n'auriez pas travailler
vous auriez autant c'est parce que je ne
voulais pas
a clairement quelque chose dit baba et
c'est vrai que ça va être aussi l'un des
grands chantiers du gouvernement c'est
de s'occuper de ces laissés pour compte
et c'est pourquoi c'est un mot fort mais
c'est bien ce dont on parle pour eux et
c'est que la situation aurait alors on
va ont écouté mais celle edouard leclerc
qui a fait beaucoup pour essayer de
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
français et qui il nous explique
contrairement à ce qu'on ne pouvait
penser que si les flamands ce n'est pas
à cause de la guerre en kryte regardé
par l'est de l'ukraine c'est pipeau
aujourd'hui miss temps l'impact de la
guerre ne se fait pas sentir ces sages
ont plus de tournesol que qui manque ici
ou qu'on envoie les gens cherchent et
c'est avec des graines qui ont été
récoltés l'année dernière donc la
spéculation et donc c'est de la
spéculation au mieux de l'anticipation
et il n'y a pas de raison de laisser les
prix partir comme ça à la hausse mais
les gentils ces magasins qui font ça
savez qu'il ya un consortium de grands
magasins cam qui s'arrangent entre eux
pour les prix et cel et c'est à eux la
honte mais parce que comme il l'a dit
très justement leclerc c'était de
l'huile de tournesol dia de l'année
dernière donc ya pas de raison de
l'augmenter mais les grands magasins ont
tous augmenté
quand même
et je suis un peu surpris et mais je
vous soutiens si ça peut vous aider moi
je fais les courses à la maison j'adore
faire les courses et je vais notamment
au supermarché de ce monsieur échec par
exemple les tomates sont à 2 90 chez moi
non je sais un prix c'est cher aussi
mais je me dis faut peut-être essayer de
trouver un système mais vous bouger pour
votre voiture partout
excuse moi je pense que
c'est en découle que senna soit par jour
et même pas
parce que j'ai pas le choix j'adore ce
que je peux pas
prendre ma place
ça fait beaucoup de peine évidemment
alors
michel edouard leclerc justement a
expliqué que lui il allait faire quelque
chose à sa mesure et avec ses moyens il
va pas aimer c'est de garantir les prix
de 120 produits regardez moi je suis
dans l'action au quotidien face à
l'inflation et avec mes collègues de
centres leclerc ce qu'on propose c'est
de repérer les 120 articles les plus
dépenser les plus achetés par les
consommateurs et de faire une sorte de
bouclier ou en garantie d'une part que
ces articles la soie il bouge pas par
exemple jusqu'au mois de juillet du 30
avril au mois de juillet il bouge pas et
si par malheur on avait mal acheté ou
qu'on nous obliger à les augmenter on
remboursera est antique et le clerc en
bout serait en rembourserait en khâgne
otages et quoi qu'on entende et ce
monsieur fait quand même
pour les français à sa mesure c'est en
laissant toujours et qu'ils vont tous
les sens à prix coûtant quand vous
entendez ce grand patron parle et vous
pouvez que c'est pas suffisant c'est
complet alors oui bien on ne peut pas y
aller peut-être pensé voilà maintenant
il faut avoir des leclerc à proximité de
son domicile
et c'est pas toujours le cas et je ne
suis pas tout seul dans ce cas là
évidemment j'ai mon cas
et représente quand même une quantité de
milliers de personnes millions peut-être
mais les retraités qui sont comme moi
qui sont dans la même situation et ce
matin j'entendais corps quelqu'un qui
pleurait qui avait que 800 euros par
mois dont moi faudrait surtout que vous
ayez la retraite que vous méritiez
sa summa trimestre 900 euros et quelques
autres de retraite et une petite
complémentaire à côté parce que j'ai
travaillé des multiples emplois
alors c'est vrai que nous nous on a une
chose d'énorme bon ben voilà on va
travailler mais notre vie quand on
entend ce témoignage bernard je vous
sens vraiment veut peiné de touché oui
évidemment enfin c'est très jeu suit
j'ai même honte si vous voulez
d'entendre ça c'est terrible c'est
inacceptable de nos jours je suis
tellement désolée pour vous madame c'est
vrai et c'est vrai qu'il faut absolument
réagir je sais que maintenant je sais
qu'on veut augmenter c'est fini là les
pensions à 800 ils vont augmenter à 1100
a priori jeunes ont besoin vous êtes au
dessus et parce que c'est juste au
dessus vous êtes à moisie mythe en fait
ça c'est le bordel d'administration
c'est n'importe quoi pour ça que ça il
faut changer ça aussi il ya beaucoup de
choses à changer qui j'espère vont
changer parce que c'est pas possible il
ya vous êtes très nombreux dans ce cas
là la france est pas pour et paupérisé
c'est sûr suite à la pandémie suite à
tout ce qui est arrivé donc là il faut
vraiment réagir énergiquement il faut
que tout le monde au moins manger à sa
faim et nantes évidemment gène n est pas
la seule dans ce cas il ya des bassières
millions de français et bien sûr des
millions et des millions et on n'était
pas au resto du coeur
juste au dessus même avec des récits
benbada psg droit rien c'est bien on va
on va regarder ce témoignage de
personnes qui comme vous 200
au début je faisais un panier de courses
pour environ 40 50 euros pour la semaine
et là on est passé sur du minimum 60
euros 70 euros et donc on est obligé de
se priver sur certains trucs donc pas de
sortie pas de restaurant
avant je faisais 60 terran maintenant il
me retrouve à 90 et chose qui est
incroyable et quand même parce que moi
il y avait beaucoup de route un y avait
50 km 100 km par jour alors ça va très
très vite voilà et et la hausse des prix
je voulais dire et ont déterminé des
grands géants comme nestlé ou danone
affirme déjà augmenté de 3% alors tarif
là qu'on fait tout le monde est assez de
gravier sur l'histoire et c'est à ça va
être un vrai problème guillaume quand
vous entendez une touche de balle
évidemment fin c'était mon envie de
l'aider et moi je veux donc pourquoi
comme pour l'essence le gouvernement ne
travaille pas en partenariat avec les
grandes surfaces pour aider et payé
peut-être une partie des courses défense
et ils l'ont fait pour l'essence de
travail total est de rembourser une
partie des frais du plein je pense que
ça peut être une des solutions concrètes
et c'est scandaleux d'entendre le
témoignage de basculer la falaise sur
tous les produits aujourd'hui on parle
même du prix du lait qui n'auront pas à
cause du lait mais à cause de la
bouteille en plastique tant que l'on met
le lait le plastique c'est fait du
pétrole donc c'est un cercle ça peut
enfin est-ce que vous avez essayé de
chez pas de vous manifester auprès
prévue vers envoyé une lettre c'est que
le we all effet les prix devraient
envoyer acquis au ministère des finances
il a pas répondu j'ai envoyé pour autre
chose pas bon pour les le statut d bcp
qui ne sont pas reconnus et qu'on n'a
passé que les baisers pulsé est vendeur
colporteur de journaux attention votre
c'était sur les faisait probablement
d'accord voilà mais j'ai la preuve on
m'a donné 40 euros de frais de carburant
ça fait même pas 1 centimes du kilomètre
et puis là on m'a viré complètement
parce que j'ai osé demander procède de
la voix du nord au tollé que ça va
s'arranger j'espère que le gouvernement
propose ça va rester comme ça avec
d'éminents personnes qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie qui seront petites
retraites qui en plus compte continuer à
travailler avec un génie merci beaucoup
dépassé de voir